I've already started with the eye color
example so I figure no harm in
continuing it let's say we live on a
planet or we're a species where there's
only two possible eye colors either blue
blue and the the genotype or the allele
for blue I'll I'll abbreviate with a
lowercase B or you could have brown eyes
brown eyes I'm doing it in the salmon
color just because I got tired of the
brown will do it uppercase B and I'll
make a few other simplifying assumptions
first of all let's assume that this is a
kind of a simple the expression of this
gene is very simple that Brown is
dominant to blue so if you have one of
each you're going to see brown eyes the
only way you're going to see blue eyes
is if you have a blue allele from each
of your parent and then the other
assumptions I'm going to make is that
this population is essentially has a
stable gene pool for this what with
respect to the eye color gene what do I
mean by that no selection no selection
is taking place no natural selection so
based on this trait so for example there
you're not more or less likely to be
able to reproduce or the number of
children you have is not going to be
larger greater dependent on what your
eye color is in this population and I'm
also going to assume that there's no
mutations no mutations so for whatever
reason a blue a chromosome that has a
blue allele can't randomly turn to a
brown or vice versa or turn into a third
color and I'm also going to assume that
I'm going to have a large population
large population and the reason why I'm
making all of these assumptions is
because I essentially want to have a
stable gene pool at least relative
relative to this gene relative to at the
eye color gene I want to be stable I
want to have a stable allele frequency
what do I mean by allele frequency
allele frequency I mean that like I said
large population but let's take a very
small population let's say that there's
two
to people in the population and you know
one one guy right here is I'll just do
it in a neutral oh let's say he's he his
genotype is Big B and lowercase B and
let's say that the other guy has blue
eyes so he has to be homozygous
recessive let's say this is the entire
population of course a population of two
can't apply to what I'm about to do but
I just want to explain allele frequency
the allele frequency here of the blue
eyes the blue-eyed allele frequency here
is what well in this population I have
exactly four alleles I only have two
individuals but they each have two
alleles so if so it's going to be 75%
75% of the alleles in this population
are blue right there's one two three
four alleles and three of them are blue
the frequency of the brown allele the
brown allele is 25% and this is
different than the actual expression if
I ask you the frequency of brown eyes
versus blue eyes so this is allele
frequency let me write that down
that's allele frequency right there if I
were to ask you Fino phenotype frequency
so let me do it phenotype if I said what
percentage of are how frequent our blue
eyes seen in my population blue eyes
well it's only one out of the two people
in my population suit say it's 50
percent and then for brown eyes you
would say it's 50 percent brown eyes
you'd say it's 50 percent so I want to
make this distinction very clear because
it can be very confusing when people
talk about allele frequency allele
frequency is literally if you were able
to go and look at the actual genotype
the actual chromosomes of every person
in the population and count how many of
them had the blue allele versus the
brown allele you would come up with this
number this is different than the actual
phenotype frequency now all of that is
just as a background because if I have
this if I had these set of assumptions
are true in my and my my population
isn't in any way evolving then my allele
frequency is going to be
roughly constant and I had to assume a
large population because the small
population is from random chance my
allele frequency could start to change
but let's say as my allele frequency is
constant then I'm in a hardy-weinberg
equilibrium Hardy hardy-weinberg
equilibrium and all this is is a
situation where the allele frequency
isn't changing equilibrium and the
reason why we're making all of those
assumptions is because if we can assume
this we can start to deduce some things
about given cell you know what we
observe what must be the genotypes in
the population or the frequencies of
different phenotypes and whatever else
so for example if if P is the frequency
of blue eyes so let me say P is equal to
the frequency of blue eyes and Q is
equal to the frequency of brown eyes
what's P plus Q going to be what's P
plus Q well everything is either going
to have blue eyes or brown eyes if this
is 50% when T percent remember this is
the allele let me make the B allele let
me make that very clear this isn't
necessarily what you observe this is the
allele itself this is the allele
frequency if you were actually to count
the chromosomes and see which ones what
percentage have the the blue allele and
what percentage have the uppercase brown
allele well every chromosomes have tests
have has to have either of those so
these are going to add up to 100% 100%
or equal to one for example if 30
percent of the alleles are blue then 70
percent are going to have to be brown
because I already told you at the
beginning of this video that we're in a
world where you either have a blue
allele or a brown allele now what if we
don't care about alleles we actually
care about we actually care about the
the frequency of the genotypes so
there's a couple of things we could do
we could literally just square both
sides of this and then think about what
that gives us so if we square both sides
of this equation you get what P plus Q
squared is P squared plus 2pq plus q
squared and you squared the other side
and is equal to 1 is why
what does this tell us what is P squared
well it's the probability that I get two
of the lowercase blue alleles right
what's the probability that I get to
that I end up with lowercase B lowercase
B is my genotype well I have to get a
lowercase B from my first parent and
that's what the probability of P and
then a lowercase B from my second parent
with the probability of P so it's P
times P so that's P squared what's Q
squared well that's the probability that
I get a big B a brown-eyed allele from
each parent because the probability from
parent one is Q and then the probability
from parent 2 is also Q so that's Q
squared right there now what's 2 PQ well
that's essentially the this entire term
is the frequency that I'm I'm a hybrid I
have a heterozygous genotype and why is
that because there's two ways that I can
be a heterozygote I could get I could be
I could be like this I could get I want
to do that other blue I could get blue
eyes from one parent and brown eyes from
the other or I could get brown eyes from
the first parent and blue eyes from the
second and I don't know anything about
these parents so if everything is you
know if I'm making no assumptions and I
just have to assume that the probability
that I get an allele from either one of
them is equal to the pop the frequency
in the population so there's two ways of
getting these the probability of each of
these ways the probability of this
combination is P times Q the probability
of this is Q times P which is the same
thing and you add them together you get
two PQ so this is essentially the
frequency of the hybrids in the
population so let's see if we can you
know I've been kind of abstract so far
let's see if we can apply this to a
real-world problem and you know
obviously I'm making some simplifying
assumptions let's say that we go into a
population let's say it's a population
of a million people reasonably large and
we observe that nine percent nine
percent have have blue eyes
blue eyes this is their phenotype this
is this is the frequency of the genotype
B lowercase B lowercase B right I
started with this phenotype blue eyes
but I know since blue is a recessive
trait that they must have two copies of
the recessive allele so this is the
frequency this the frequency of having
two lowercase B's is nine percent well
if you just look here I just showed you
that that's also equal to P squared P
squared is equal to nine percent and how
do you think about that well P is a
probability of getting a blue allele
it's the frequency of the blue allele in
the population in order to get two of
them you have to multiply P by itself
twice so what's the frequency of the
blue allele in the population P is equal
to the square root of 0.09 which is 0.3
so if you went and actually counted all
of the alleles in the population you
would actually find that 30% of them are
the lowercase blue now a much smaller
percentage of people only nine percent
show the blue eyes because you need two
of them you have a thirty percent chance
of getting it from your mom and a thirty
percent chance of getting it from your
dad so what's the probability of what's
what's the frequency of a of a
brown-eyed allele so what's the
frequency of the brown-eyed allele well
we know that the frequency of the blue
eyes plus the brown eyes is 100% so
that's going to be seventy percent if 30
percent of all of the chromosomes or of
all of the alleles in the population are
blue the other 70% are going to have to
be brown so what percentage of my
population are going to be oh there's a
couple of things we can do what
percentage of my population are going to
have well I'll do an easy one what
percentage of my population are going to
have brown eyes so if I just look at the
phenotype brown eyes I don't even have
to use any of you formulas for this one
I already told you 9% have blue eyes so
the rest must have brown eyes so 91%
have brown eyes
I have brown eyes now we just said that
we have 9% have blue eyes 91 2% have
brown eyes what percentage of the
population are going to be homozygous
for brown eyes so they need they need to
have the capital B from both parents
well we know that the frequency of the
capital B allele is 70%
so what what percent are going to be
homozygous dominant you draw that
homozygous dominant
well the frequency the gap there is
going to be Q squared they're going to
have to get a Q they're gonna have to
get a perk ace B from each parent so
that's going to be 0.7 squared which is
equal to 0.49 or 49% 49% so just
starting already from that one idea from
that one idea that 9% have blue eyes
blue eyes we've already been able to
deduce that 91% must have brown eyes
brown eyes and of the 91% of brown eyes
of the whole population 49% this isn't
49% of the ninety-one this is 49% of the
population 49% are homozygous dominant
homozygous dominant and then what
percentage of the population is going to
be is are going to be hybrids
well hybrids also have brown eyes and
they not homozygous dominant so what the
remainder here so what is that
and that's 42% 42% 42% are going to be
are going to be hybrids hybrids and if
we go back to the the hardy-weinberg
equation we see that so we get you know
P plus Q has to be equal to well 100% or
I could just write equal to 1 and we
figured out that P was 30% that's the
frequency of the blue-eyed allele the
actual trait not not the observation of
it or the genotype and the frequency of
the brown eyes was 70%
and then this is actually a breakdown
when you square that so we also know
that P squared plus 2pq plus q squared
is equal to one this is the percentage
of the population that has blue eyes
they have two blue alleles so that's
nine percent this is the percentage of
the population that has two brown
alleles homozygous dominant
so that is 49% and then this is the
remainder this - PQ this whole term
right here is what's left over so c99
plus is 58 this is going to be 42
percent 42 percent are hybrids and if I
said if I just talked about phenotypes
I'd say 9% have blue eyes and then the
remainder 91 percent have brown eyes so
hopefully you found that reasonably
useful just from kind of very simple
deduction it's almost you know it's it's
it's it's it's almost kind of silly that
you know this is almost a separate
principle because you can kind of deduce
this from very basic ideas and you can
square both sides of that you can come
up with some fairly fascinating results
about what's going on in population
because what we can observe may be the
frequency let's say some disease only
happens when you when when a when
someone is homozygous recessive so you
can figure you can go and see okay what
percentage of the population has that
disease but then doing the math that we
just did in this video you can figure
out what percentage of the population
have the have the allele for the disease
they're carriers for the disease but
they don't actually show it and that
would be the hybrids right there so
there's actually a pretty powerful tool
you've just learned